est-ce que je peux me faire livrer by
alloresto devant le match possible ça je
préfère manger ou à la maison mais
traiteur mais devant le match forcément
je m'en fous je ne bouge tous les pores
que j'ai ryan si tu me regarde je suis
fait pour toi je suis milhas dans la la
land est ce que tu m'entends bordel je
gagne au loto et après je m'achète une
dizaine de make sure adoptant
adopteunmec.com je rachète ce site
bordel préfère les soumet donne moi la
tude mai mais c'est quoi ce qui ampute a
en même temps les amis ça va
les amis tisser des fois une rôtie
séparés puis si c'est une véritable amie
elle sera heureuse pour nous jeudi nous
horrible horrible mireille mathieu en
playmobil matière playmobil seager les
vêtements deux arrière arrière grand
mère qu'elle avait des 2sous sympa qui
peut faire vintage c'est à la mode du
vintage [ __ ] independent' woman je
paie le reste au jeu le fracasse sa race
devant le resto et j'appelle un ibère